les 7h49 léa salamé votre invité ce
matin et président du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat
bonjour bruno retailleau bonjour les fm
merci d'être avec nous ce matin
l'émotion est forte avec après la perte
de 13 de nos militaires français au mali
c'est le plus lourd bilan humain pour
l'armée française depuis le drakkar à
beyrouth il y a près de 40 ans quel
sentiment vous traverse on attend un
sentiment bien sûr d'émotion hommage à
nos grands morts qu'on m'avait dit un
jour clemenceau à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale
c'était le 11 novembre 1918 donc hommage
à ses héros
bien sûr mes pensées à leurs familles
vous savez que on a malheureusement un
papa qui est sénateur et qui a perdu 1
ses fils jean marie bockel
absolument mais aujourd'hui je pense que
la france fait le travail est fait
travail pour l'europe là bas mais
beaucoup de choses doivent changer
qu'est ce qui doit changer il faut
rester ce terrible c'est ce que j'allais
vous demandez ce terrible drame repose
la question de notre présence ou celle
des soldats meurent la situation se
dégrade sur place devons-nous partir ou
rester si on reste on reste pour combien
de temps plus de 40 soldats sont morts
bien sûr il faut rester faut pas limiter
les américains lorsqu'ils sont partis
syrie l'afghanistan et est même
d'ailleurs l'irak ce serait la double
peine on aurait payé le prix fort le
prix du sang et on n'aurait pas obtenu
le résultat mais on ne peut pas rester
dans les conditions dans lesquelles nous
sommes aujourd'hui ça n'est pas la
question d'efficacité de nos forces et
sont efficaces nous ne sommes pas seuls
il ya l'onu la minustah
il ya le g5 sahel et puis il ya barkan
voilà ce que il faut proposer d'abord
pour ce qui concerne la minus marre ils
sont enfermés dans leurs casernes ils
passent du temps à se protéger eux mêmes
ça ne va pas on redéfinit le redit leur
position et surtout leur feuille de
route
deuxième chose pour ce qui concerne
barkan il faut un commandement français
qui intègre les forces spéciales
définitivement on lui aussi là-bas pour
l'horreur quoi précisé ça veut dire
qu'il faut
marc khanne si j'ose dire d'autres pays
que l'allemagne par exemple nous aide
elle nous aide sur de la logistique très
bien mais beaucoup de pays européens
certains pays européens pardon ont des
forces spéciales qui sont très aguerri
il faut les mettre
bien sûr à disposition sous un même
commandement ce commandement est
évidemment français dans le cas de marc
calvet somme qu'on va vers ça florence
parly je l' ai entendu j'espère que le
chef d'état major des armées tout à
l'heure pour à vous confirmer
troisième élément le mali le g
axa elles dont fait partie de ma vie il
ya un vrai problème c'est que le
président mbk fait pas le travail
il n'est pas associé au contraire il ne
remplit pas le minimum des missions
régaliennes de sécurité ou sociale
l'éducation de la santé alors il ne veut
pas appliquer les accords d'alger de
on est très exigeant avec lui on lui
fait comprendre que ça va bien on est là
et nous en prennent pompéi en paie le
prix du sang alors il doit
impérativement coopérer mais vous dites
ce matin contrairement à certaines voix
qu'on entend notamment la france un sur
dix qui disent on ne comprend plus cette
guerre on ne comprend plus à quoi on
sert en afrique au sahel
moi je vais vous dire à 6h demain on
part c'est toute l'afrique un territoire
presque grand comme l'europe qui peut
tomber dans un gigantesque khalifa
africains et là bas une fois que le
califat aura été institué ce sera des
morts en france le terrorisme
on lutte sur le front extérieur et on
lutte sur le front intérieur et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai toujours
indiqué que la mort de nos soldats nous
obligeaient y compris sur le front
intérieur être courageux à ne rien céder
on y reviendra longuement avec le chef
d'état major des armées a invité
exceptionnel
8h20 bruno retailleau on en vient à la
grève du 5 décembre qui s'annonce
massive à la sncf à la ratp les
syndicats appellent à une grève
illimitée
vous voulez créer d'ici le 5 décembre un
droit au transport public garanti c'est
quoi ça veut dire que vous voulez
réquisitionner le personnel le personnel
gréviste c'est simplement que ya le
droit de grève il est garanti un autre
principe constitutionnel qui doit être
garanti principe de la continuité des
services publics moi je veux simplement
au moment où beaucoup de français les
plus fragiles ceux qui n'ont pas de
solution alternative qui dépend des
transports publics qui sont importants
pour notre environnement
je pense que le moment est venu de se
dire au moins mettons nous autour d'une
table et il ya un minimum garanti c'est
à dire je propose un tiers ou aux heures
de pointe c'est parfaitement veillard
aux heures de pointe
un tiers du trafic aux heures de pointe
lors de pointe étant définie comme la
plage horaire où il ya le plus de
desserte dans une journée c'est donc le
matin et le soir on peut le droit de
grazailles cas c'est le droit
non le graet bref il est bien sûr il est
fondamental mais ça n'est pas un droit
au blocage à la prise d'otage de la
france je crois que il ya un point
d'équilibré je le cherche ce point
d'équilibré
peut-être qu'on me dira c'est pas 33 %
c'est pas un tiers si un cas mais ce
point d'équilibré pour la conciliation
des deux droit constitutionnel que sont
le droit de grève que sont le principe
de syrte de continuité des services
publics
c'est absolument essentiel est la mise
des transports elisabeth bord nous a
répondu vertement que c'était vraiment
de la communication que de déposer à dix
jours d'une grève une proposition de loi
elle raille votre sens du timing
politique mais je n'ai pas compté nos
propositions de loi il y en a quatre ou
cinq on a déposé depuis deux ans on les
dépose régulièrement celle ci est très
affiné parce que justement on l'a
travaillé depuis longtemps c'est
exactement ce que j'avais fait mon texte
sur les black blocks on m'avait dit mais
ces quelques semaines non moi je l'avais
proposé au moment dé à dist de nantes
je l'avais déposé juste après le 1er mai
2018 quand les black blocs avaient
pourri justement la manifestation du
travail des grâces des grands syndicats
n'avaient pas pu manifester sur le fond
maintenant bruno retailleau le
gouvernement répète ces derniers jours
qu'ils iront jusqu'au bout que les
régimes spéciaux c'est fini que c'est un
statut d'une autre époque que les
revendications des cheminots sont
corporatistes est-ce que vous approuvez
tout cela non mais il ya deux choses
d'abord on peut pas dire on peut pas
gonfler les muscles en prenant et en
désignant des boucs émissaires
notamment sur les régimes c'est sous moi
je suis pour la fin des régimes spéciaux
mais pour autant mails macro ne peut pas
se cacher derrière son petit doigt
il suffit pas pour qu'une réforme soit
bonne de désigner des boucs émissaires
c'est ce qui fait systématiquement pour
les retraités dans le cas de la
désindexation c'était des nantis ensuite
c'était les élus souvenez-vous bas dans
ce ton maire les gaulois réfractaires
etc
il ya toujours cette idée du bouc
émissaire maintenant cette réforme ne
marche pas elle est anxiogène pour deux
raisons d'abord les brumeuse le
calendrier les cacophonies on ne sait
pas où on va
mais surtout elle est profondément
injuste chaque jour qui passe la liste
justement des perdants s'allongent les
mères de famille les calculs on les a
maintenant une mère de famille avec deux
enfants qu'ils gagnent tenez vous bien
1250 euros par mois et va perdre par an
1600 euros a cédé 2,3 pour parler de
trois enfants oui pareil
1 le même salaire par mois 1200 euros et
la perte s'est pratiquement plus d'un
salaire par an jean paul delevoye a
prévu des bonus de 5 % accordée aux deux
parents dès le premier enfant mais ces
paliers ça mais c'est faux mais enfin
c'est vrai qu'actuellement mais je vous
prends le cas d'une femme et ses trois
enfants de trois enfants 5% trois
enfants multiples r3 ça fait 15 le
système actuel c'est pour trois enfants
10 % pour chaque parent 20% deuxième
chose
le système actuel parce que les femmes
sont désavantagées elle touche moins 40%
de moins de retraite parce que les
carrières professionnelles sont souvent
interrompus heurté et aujourd'hui on a
une forme de primes aux trimestres par
enfant vous avez huit trimestres par
enfant vitry mais c'est considérable et
d'où ce bonus pour comprendre il n'y
aura rien hélas y aura rien pareil pour
les veuves les pensions de réversion
aujourd'hui c'est notre mari à 55 ans
vous toucher la pension de reversions
vous êtes bien faudra 62 ans vous êtes
sur 24 vous la connaissez en fait la
réforme mais mes personnages veulent
accoler parallèle approche le sénat a
fait un travail très minutieux on
continue à le faire et on n'est pas pour
rien justement dans le calcul pour les
mères de famille de 1,2 et 3 enfants et
on voit bien que cette haine elle ne
vole pas comme 10 mg/l magret ne marche
pas parce que le système est complexe et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le machiniste ne
comprend pas sa machine
voilà là là là de matinée elle et l'a
dit et si les français elie et si les
français vont projeter leur
mécontentement sur par exemple la
manifestation les grèves du 5 décembre
ça n'est pas parce qu'ils veulent des
régimes spéciaux c'est tout simplement
parce que il se solidarise c'est comme
une grève par procuration et c'est grave
parce que le système français est un des
meilleurs
le taux descend allez vous dire qu'on va
dire pardon c'est ce que dit richard
ferrand notamment il dit ne soyons pas
pleurnichard on a le meilleur système de
santé au monde
en tout cas on est envié à aller est-ce
que vous avez l'impression très faux nez
trop négatifs comme dit emmanuel macron
qu'on ait des pleurnichards comme
richard ferrand ça c'est la technique du
bouc émissaire s'est jamais de sa faute
c'est toujours la faute des français
dont il est au pouvoir maintenant depuis
deux ans et demi à lui de prendre ses
responsabilités la prochaine retraite si
jamais elle je pense qu'elle ne se fera
pas parce que elle fabriquera des
nouveaux pauvres
le système actuel de notre propre
retraite
c'est quand même intéressant pour les
plus de 65 ans on a deux fois et demie
moins de pauvres en moyenne que les
grands pays de cdo mais le problème
c'est que vous êtes pour la grève du 7
décembre je la soutiens pas je dis que
cette non ces nouvelles la réforme est
mauvaise parce qu'elles ne pensent pas
la démographie or un régime de retraite
par répartition c'est l' équilibre entre
les actifs et les inactifs si vous
cassez la politique familiale vous
casser le régime de retraite par
répartition en faïence et l'avenir c'est
à dire penser une politique de la
démographie merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci les gars